On November 28th, Nancy Pelosi cleared a
major hurdle in her quest to become
Speaker of the House for the second time.
What do all Americans think about her
and what about Democrats? In November,
Gallup reported that Pelosi has long
been viewed more negatively than positively.
In the organization's latest 2018 poll,
29% had a favorable opinion
of her and 53% an unfavorable one.
Should she be speaker again when the
party takes control in January?
In the mid-November CBS News poll, 30%
nationally said that they would prefer Pelosi
to be the next speaker and 57% another
Democrat. 49% of Democrats preferred her
and 40% another Democrat. In a late
November Harvard-Harris online survey,
33% nationally said that the House
should reelect her, while 67% said it was
time for a new leader. Democrats preferred
a new leader by a slim margin, 52 to 48%.
Pelosi is formidable, but it's clear there
is an appetite for change among Democrats.
Should Nancy Pelosi be speaker for a second time?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.